in this video i will show you how you
can easily calculate online a d-test for
independent samples just visit
datadept.net and go to the statistics
calculator
if you want to use your own data please
clear the table and then copy your data
into this table i will use the example
data if you copied your own data into
this table
you will see here all your variables
we want to calculate a t-test
let's say we want to investigate if the
gender has an impact to the salary so we
simply select the salary and the gender
now data tab knows that we want to
calculate an unpaired t-test
if the conditions are not fulfilled we
can also calculate the non-parametric
test the man with new test but we want
to calculate the t-test
now if we scroll down
we will see the results in this table we
can see the descriptive statistics here
we can see the box plots
and in this table we will see the
results we can read the p-value in this
table depending if the variances are
equal or not equal further we can simply
click on this button summary and words
and data tab will give you the
interpretation of the results the mail
group had lower values for the variable
salary than the female group so the mean
test of variance equalities has shown
that the variance equality can be
assumed
a t test for independent samples equal
variance assumed showed this divergence
was not statistically significant
so that is how easy you can calculate an
unpaired t-test online with data tab
i hope you liked this video and see you
next time